hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one of the goods that we all want
to some degree and enjoy to some degree
is respect
or honor or prestige however you want to
put it
what that means is having other people
look to us
as being valuable being worthy
having some sort of goodness that they
recognize and when i was actually
reading through this
i started thinking about something that
aristotle doesn't talk about
very explicitly achievement
we often want to be recognized for
achievements
and and sometimes the mere recognition
itself
can become a kind of achievement for a
lot of people
when somebody wants to be you know a
celebrity for celebrity sake
they're important because they're
honored by a lot of people they're
famous to a lot of people
what's really behind it there's really
nothing there
other than the fact that a lot of people
are saying hey you know a great person
some people are really obsessed with
grades
and um the question they forget to ask
themselves what does the grade actually
signify
it doesn't signify you're a great person
it signifies you
performed if the class is set up right
you actually performed
these tasks and did them the right way
at a high level of competency or
something you
mastered this set of skills right a
great an a
without actually doing anything is kind
of valueless
it's empty it doesn't mean anything but
some people will take that a just as
much as
um any you know the earned the achieved
a or even the one you know from the
teacher says
none of you are getting a's and you rest
an a out of that right
then that really feels good doesn't it
um
now all of that kind of feeds into this
because we want to think about
why people want to be honored what's
going on
with that and
here aristotle is actually going to talk
about four different kinds of
people so the great soul
person deserves oops
they deserve a lot
because they actually are genuinely good
they they have
virtues
and along with that they play much
they know their genuine value
that doesn't mean that they're a jerk
all the time and make everybody you know
like
show me honor you know make sure that
you tell me what a great person i am
because that would actually be not doing
this sort of thing that way that would
be
slipping away from that we're going to
see some of these conditions
in just a moment
what would be opposed to that well um
over on the side of
you can have somebody who deserves
something
but claims less than they deserve
this is what aristotle calls the
small soul
angry and it's the people who are sort
of
unassuming they they put themselves down
they don't treat themselves as having
the value that they actually do and
other people are like what the hell is
wrong with you
you could have gone for that position
you know that would have been perfect
for you
i don't think i'm the right guy for the
job you know
they think less people like them than
people actually do
they value themselves lower than they
they ought to they may not be as great
as the great sold person
but they do deserve more than they
are claiming and because they claim less
they're likely to get less
as a result because how does society
work who tends to get
things does it come to you just by merit
what's your experience do you do you
generally get things just by somebody
like looking at your scores and saying
oh yeah you fit in here or is it the
person who actually like you know says
hey
over here who who tends to get this
stuff who are you
i would say people who like work really
hard in going downhill
go ahead and take the initiative
themselves yeah that taking the
initiative is something that's missing
here
now on the other hand on the side of
success and you all know people like
this
there are some who
they may deserve something they're not
totally full of you know
bs um or all smoking beers but they
claim
more
and they want to be treated better than
they actually deserve
i i had this experience with students at
my previous job
where they would come in and you know um
not so much in my class but a lot of
other people's classes they have a sort
of a bad
classroom management kind of attitude
you know putting their feet up on the
desk and
like talking and stuff like that you
know when we're trying to get started
and
all those are things that don't happen
that much here in america could happen a
lot at other places
and you know i would say hey knock it
off
we're going to start class and then they
get mad at me yeah you've got to you've
got to respect me
and i would say what
you're you're here to take the class
right
this is a cooperative activity and
you're only one person in that
and you're actually disrupting the class
um
i'll show you respect i'm already
showing you respect by actually
explaining this to you
instead of just kicking you out of my
class like i could
or marking you down um
but they they weren't getting that in
order to
as we say in order to get respect you
have to what give respect right
so you have to do that first somebody
like that doesn't get it
they they always think that everybody
should give them more respect more
prestige
more honor more positions than they
are getting and oftentimes they can't be
satisfied
you know you give in to them and you
give them the nice spot
you know fine we'll give you the title
you can be the uh
editor-in-chief even though we'll all do
the work and they're still not happy
because there's there's this desire and
then we have more and more
now the the fourth type
is um
little but claims
there are some people he calls this the
modest
there are some people who actually
they say look you know i'm not supposed
to be the one in charge
um because i'm not really suited for
that and that's okay with me
i'm fine with just doing my bit part
i don't have to like show off to anybody
they're not like these people who
don't really have that much going for
them but want to feel that they have a
lot going for them
and they're not only these people over
here who are you know sort of
downplaying themselves lowballing their
their value they understand
they're really not that that great um
and he says it's kind of like the great
soul person and that they actually have
the right
evaluation of what they deserve what
separates the great soul person
from this kind of person is the fact
that the great soul person
really does deserve a lot
because they really are virtuous
they have good character traits they
they contribute
so you can't have uh this virtue
of greats oldness or
magnanimity without having other virtues
so you know being courageous for example
you need to be a courageous person
in order to be this or a just person
there's kind of a reciprocal
relationship it kind of brings the
virtues together
so somebody you know who's got a you
know right estimate of themselves and
say i don't really have a lot of virtues
i'm not a bad guy
but i'm not a great guy either so you
know don't talk to me as if i'm like
you know mother teresa because i
give a buck to the bum on the corner um
just you know let's keep this in
perspective
they're they're actually on track this
person
gets to say yeah okay i guess in a
certain respect maybe i am like mother
teresa because they really are like
mother teresa
um i suppose actually mother teresa from
aristotle's point of view you know where
she'd end up
over here this is where aristotle is
very different
than later um christian authors who saw
this as a form of pride
um pridefulness when really maybe this
is more
you know pride being being prideful than
what one doesn't actually happen
so what else does he tell us about this
well
um
who are they interested in getting
respect from
everybody nobody
something in between yeah maybe leaving
people that they consider respectable
yeah there's a good way to put it people
over here will take it from whoever they
can get it
because they're so hungry for it and
they're always insecure about not
actually
measuring up to what they're saying
about themselves
the man anonymous person is not
interested
in everybody's opinion they're not
interested they wouldn't be going for
example on american idol
because they don't care what the crowd
thinks and they wouldn't care what the
judges say
they might be going on you know shows
where
there's a better judging of talent or
something like that it's not so
much popularity
well they probably wouldn't be doing
singing anything they'd probably be
doing something like philanthropy
or you know trying to run an industry or
change the world in some way
not that you can't change the world
through singing right
but they're they're not going to be
concerned about popularity
they're going to be concerned about the
people who actually
have something to contribute to the
conversation because they actually know
what they're talking about
so i mean this is something to think
about who do you
all of you should be concerned with
these questions about what you deserve
and how much you actually claim think
about who you
want to hold you up in
high esteem whose opinion
counts for you that's that's an
important determiner
for this um
what else they they want to be honored
for great things
they're not particularly interested in
being honored for trivial things
so you know they'll show up to the
to the the dinner where they're getting
some
small award and you know be good about
it
but they're not seeking that sort of
stuff out whereas people over here
get obsessed about that sort of stuff
they really care about the smaller like
employee of the month
unless you're at a you know a place
where that's really a big thing
you probably shouldn't care about
employee of the month some places
actually rotate it
you know by so nobody feels left out
did you know that but people like this
are really obsessed about that
um the magnanimous they want to be
honored for having done something that
really
means something that changes things for
the better
something noble um
this person over here what's missing in
their respect
is that they're not seeking out any of
those
so what else can you say they have a do
measure with respect to assessing wealth
and power
and birth in a couple different ways
wealth and power and birth are three
things
that are what aristotle calls goods of
fortune these are things
that that happen to people and very
often
they didn't like you know deserve them
or choose them or anything like that
you didn't choose who your parents are
right so if your parents are rich
and you're rich as a result it's not
like you
you know you made that money yourself
right
um same thing with like noble birth
that's not a big deal over here
but that was a big deal back in ancient
greece and you know we could think about
people
who are kids of celebrities kids of uh
politicians people like that and then
power um does having power make you a
good person
what's what's your experience of that
yeah it depends on how you use it
very much yeah and sometimes you didn't
realize what a bad person a person was
until they got some power right
even just a little bit sometimes and so
the magnanimous person
doesn't value these things tonight
because they realize these are very
arbitrary
that doesn't mean that they'll like you
know turn their nose up at rich people
or something like that
but it's interesting he says that they
will be kind of haughty with rich people
and they will be more um
how does he put it more uh
modest more
open towards the people who are lower
down on the scale
so you know here's here's a good way to
put this here's a metaphor
my mother was a secretary um a good
portion of her life
and from her i learned by
observation that if you want to get
something done in an
office you need to make friends with the
secretaries because
that's where things actually happen and
they can kill you or they can
you know pave your way to success
losses are are important but secretaries
stay and bosses go
and secretaries often have a much better
understanding about what's going
on in the organization than the
executives did
now how do people talk to secretaries
most of the time
yeah yeah talk down to them expect them
to do things for them
yeah i knew a guy when i was in graduate
school a professor who did that
department secretary who'd been there 35
years
knew everybody at the university and
with just one conversation he screwed
himself for
like the next 10 years to come because
he did that down
and ordered her around um the
magnanimous person is not going to do
that
they treat the the people who have the
you know the
lower positions as if they really matter
and they treat the people who are in the
higher positions as if they're just
peers
that's tough to do because what's our
natural inclination
to suck up to the rich and powerful and
to look down
on the people who are you know for the
moment
below us um
kind of a good apprenticeship that i had
thanks to my mom
i'm very thankful for that um
similarly they when it comes to benefits
the magnanimous person likes giving out
benefits
doesn't like receiving them in part
because receiving them
makes it you know feel like you're
you're actually not as you know
on top of things as you are but
giving benefits is a way to show you
know that you
actually are good that you do deserve a
lot
um people over here are much more
interested in receiving benefits
particularly of honor the uh
the magnanimous person also realizes
that the high
born the rich and the powerful will
often tend to
think of themselves as like being like
the magnanimous because they
they think that they do deserve a lot
and they do often claim a lot
but they don't have good good reasons
for doing so
and think about money for example um
just like power it's what you usually
right
so have you known some people who are
complete jerks uh
and are rich in your in your lifetime
they're not making animists right do
people who are
rich and are jerks do they think that
they deserve a lot
do a lot of other people think that they
deserve a lot yeah
do they claim a lot usually
yes but they're not magnetic
so it's not just deserving a lot and
claiming a lot or thinking that you do
that makes that the case it's what you
do it's how you characteristically
behave
the other thing that he says about the
magnanimous that i think is really
interesting
there's an openness to them they say
what they think
they're not concerned about you know
appealing to other people's
images of them maintaining those images
in any sort of artificial way they want
to be known for
actually being good
and making the claim to that on that
basis
so if they don't like you they'll let
you know or they don't like what you're
doing they'll let you know
on the other hand if they love what
you're doing they'll let you know about
that too
think about how many times we have to
kind of cover up
what we like and what we don't like and
how that
tends to force us into one of these
extremes
which is it really isn't good for us
now let's we've talked a lot about the
magnanimous person
uh and i think this this one's pretty
straightforward people who are
are actually prideful for vain as
aristotle says
they claim for themselves more than they
deserve they're not claiming it for
themselves on the basis of real
achievements because otherwise they
would they would deserve what they claim
right
this is like the person who gets a's by
taking all the easy classes
and then says aha i've got a perfect
report card
sure you do but it doesn't mean the same
thing as somebody who took tough classes
who actually
measured up right a lot of people mix up
achievements and recognition
and they think that somehow the
recognition is itself an achievement
the recognition only really matters
for somebody who sees things rightly if
there's a real achievement behind it
um
now what about people over here
i just think for mayor students this is
more of a danger
than this
um you're not reaching your potential
you might be
but then you're not letting anybody know
that you're reaching your potential
and there is a tendency to to
tell us not to to brag right it requires
some
some work to overcome the renaissance
that many of us feel
like you know have you ever heard the
phrase you have to sell yourself
like in job interviews things like that
you really do and it's okay to sell
yourself
if you really have the goods to back it
up then it still feels kind of weird at
first
but you need to do it aristotle's
feeling
you you have to actually be able
to be comfortable with saying yes i am
good at this
i am the person for the job not my way
of like you know
making stuff up or inflating your
your resume but a lot of you are really
solid students who have a lot of great
experience
pretty good pretty good thinkers from
what i can tell from your writing
and often tend to be self-deprecating
it's hard to overcome that tendency
particularly when it's been pushing us
we should be we should be modest right
if you're if you're here this is good if
you really don't have
you know some skills to put on the table
on some occasions
don't try to make anything up you know
of it and try to be in a big shot
but if you really have something you
don't want to be the person who gets
passed over all the time
because they don't claim anything a lot
of other people
in their lives look at these people
they're like what's going on
why aren't you getting safe promoted why
aren't you getting this opportunity
why aren't you being recognized for this
because they
they don't they convey to other people
i'm not really worthy of this
i don't really deserve this
so those are the virtues advice is
concerned with
honor on a large scale